R8 news now investigators learning that  the Mother-in-law of the man accused of  shooting a Metro Police veteran warned  police about her son-in-law just minutes  before he shot and killed officer Trung  Tai and then shot her 24 year old Tyson  Hampton's wife was actually the one who  called police last Thursday saying  Hampton had hit her and she was bleeding  officer Ty and another officer responded  now documents that are eight news now  investigators obtained say Hampton's  mother-in-law called dispatchers minutes  before saying Hampton was known to carry  guns and as our eight and eight news now  investigators reported just last week  Hampton faced a gun-related charge two  years ago and was known to pull out his  gun during confrontations  by the way a public visitation for  officer Tai is scheduled for next  Thursday afternoon